hausse du prix de l'essence hausse du
panier d'épicerie andré langlois nous
présente la situation inquiétante de
certains organismes offrant de l'aide
alimentaire
[Musique]
depuis le début de la pandémie plusieurs
nouveaux organismes ont vu le jour pour
contrer l'insécurité alimentaire comme
ici dans ce local de la rue sainte
catherine où des étudiants de l'uqam
travaillent à la préparation de bach
alimentaire
ils déchargent le camion de denrées
récoltées à moisson montréal
ensemble ils tentent d'aider leur
communauté à mieux se nourrir en ces
temps difficiles on est tous étudiants
et en ce moment fait c'est c'est
toujours bien de mettre la main à la
pâte et pouvoir aider d'autres étudiants
dans les deux ans ce carnage fait
selon l'institut national de la santé
publique vingt pour cent des québécois
ont déclaré vivre de l'insécurité
alimentaire
parmi eux 40 % de jeunes âgés de 18 à 24
ans 10 tant souffrir c'est le compte est
bon les gens en détresse et les côtés de
répondre à tout le monde
lysandre et la directrice mais aussi
l'une des initiatrices de ce projet du
bac alimentaire l'organisme est né en
raison de la pandémie la demande est
juste de plus en plus grande la demande
à moisson montréal est de plus en plus
grande c'est julian a ajouté 300
organise cette année est obligé d'unités
mais bac parce que jugée pas assez de
nourriture j'ai pas assez de talent de
partenaires financiers ça me prendrait
peut-être plus de partenaires parce que
la demande ne cesse d'augmenter j'ai
même des gens d'autres universités qui
m'écrivent d'ailleurs qui m'écrivent
pour voir si on peut les aider mais
j'peux pas parce que j'arrive pas à fond
des choses pour lui que ça sente pas
s'arrêter ça semble empirer
à
l'entrepôt de moisson laval josek fait
le même constat
banal howie l'eterne beaucoup mais le
parler tant qu'icône a eu presque peau
et puis pomme de terre c'est zéro les
denrées fraîches diminue alors que la
clientèle augmente échange on a beaucoup
de gens qui travaillent les gens qui
travaillent à temps partiel ou des gens
qui sont à faible revenu mais pierre et
fut la réponse du soul avec un salaire
minimum les tarés pu lui pas rejoignez
du bout
[Musique]
la pandémie au fait plus exacerbée ces
inégalités sociales locke les personnes
les plus affectées par la crise
économique et au premier chef c'est les
femmes donc déjà les inégalités de genre
les inégalités entre les groupes
les groupes raciaux ou racisées si je
peux dire les étudiants ça fait partie
des gens aussi c'est souvent cachés on
n'en parle pas beaucoup me suis dit oh
ben pour aider ma mère avec l'épicerie
bout je participe et puis je vais aller
chercher la nourriture ici ou bactéries
menteur a décrit comme les religieux
si c'est des choses qui est des fois on
peut pas se permettre trop donc
compréhensible et digne de personnes
quand même temps je peux me procurer de
la nourriture pour aider ma famille la
majorité des gens ils demandent de la
viande je veux de la viande mais ça fait
longtemps j'ai pas mangé ou bien est ce
que je peux en avoir les seuils de le
remettre au moins deux ligues mineures
c'est faire des choses constate au moins
2000 lumineuse qui condamne du temps
mais un ton en même temps quand de
tomates toujours pressés un défaut quand
de légumes ça dépend de ce qu'on ne le
pas ce qu'on sait faire des paniers
qu'il y brille exactement selon le
chercheur sébastien rioux les mesures
dette gouvernementale sont insuffisants
ce que sa demande c'est que
l'alimentation n'est pas un droit dans
notre société essentiellement c'est de
la charité il ya évidemment l'aide
sociale sera minimum mais ce sont
essentiellement des mesures de pauvreté
quand qu'on est en insécurité
alimentaire grave pour bus privés de
repas pendant tout des journées entières
ya vraiment la fin qui s'installe
[Musique]
c'est des gens qui jamais qui aurait
pensé venir nous demander glide l'idée
je pensais pas vous existez avoir su
j'aurais demandé depuis une on l'a
remarqué dès le début mais j'avais honte
de demander de l'aide
c'est la journée de la distribution
chaque étudiant inscrit doit débourser 5
dollars pour récupérer un bac
alimentaires d'une valeur d'environ 120
dollars sans compter tous les extras
offert au comptoir du fromage du yogourt
des oeufs certains étudiants font des
échanges
et surtout financièrement parce que
bassong dollars pour tous a jamais ça
ailleurs tout ce qui existe à toi et
c'est des choses que tu ne veux pas te
laisse s'envoler de nouveau les shows
comme saab en main cherche dans les
supermarchés c'est vraiment très cher
mais ici on vend seulement 5 $ par
chaque bas
la matinée est très occupé les besoins
sont grands
les gens sont contents france et
beaucoup de légumes cette semaine
beaucoup de frais légumes on est content
de ses quelque chose
des semaines et qui permet vraiment
d'études est beaucoup plus à l'aise avec
beaucoup moins d'anxiété matériel les
étudiants et leurs parents s'ils pensent
les pattes docteur ça permet aussi de
manger des fruits des légumes des choses
un peu plus de différentes c'est une
solidarité effet que saleh des bienfaits
et et sur le
sentiment d'appartenance à ta communauté
ta santé mentale ta santé social tente
et interactions avec les autres mais
tout ça c'est quand même porté à bout de
bras l'avait promis par contre le faire
dans les premiers six mois chaque jeudi
les gens pleuraient ils pas un jeu vidéo
j'ai pas pleurer j'en parle ça sans
motif et pour juger pas pleurer parce
que des gens étaient tellement triste
allemande en usage totalement avoir
prouvé
à l'heure actuelle alameda j'ai 100
familles de plus de janvier à mars par
rapport à l'année passée avec le suisse
au web on est obligé d'acheter le faire
des achats
en complémentarité avec nos produits
qu'on a un don
[Musique]
lysandre soit doubler l'offre de bach
alimentaire à 500 par semaine elle tente
de trouver des solutions elle aussi doit
parfois acheter des aliments ça va me
demander d'acheter plus de nourriture
par moi même avec le prix de la voiture
mais c'est
ça on est comme rendu le on est dans un
moment où est ce que la demande est
énorme de j'aimerais y répondre mais que
je manque de sciences la maman d'avis en
fait la question de l'alimentation et de
la sécurité alimentaire devrait être un
droit de vote droit social il personne
n'a un état comme le québec qui devrait
avoir c'est venu avec la pandémie mais
quand on a commencé le projet on s'est
dit on aimerait que le projet perdure
après la pandémie parce que de toute
façon pas la pandémie 126 200 m la
pandémie je m'en sers mans s'est dit que
ça serait pertinent dans vos salles pour
les étudiants étudiantes mikami une
prise de conscience à faire mais ça va
prendre un certain courage politique
pour mettre en place de réelles
politiques qui vont avoir un impact sur
la vie des gens